good morning Hank it's Wednesday great
top ten list on Monday today it's time
for my top 10 list top 10 animal power
moves gotta love power moves power move
number 10 belongs to the bombardier
beetle Hank when the bombardier beetle
is threatened it turns around and sprays
boiling hot acid out of its butt
pound move number nine giraffes you know
how I love giraffes and giraffes of it
the Chuck Norris of the animal kingdom
when they roundhouse kicked you you
forget what time it is a giraffe kick
has been known to decapitate a lion
power move number eight and one of my
personal favorites comes from Canter's
giant softshell turtle now if we know
the Power Move for regular Turtles it's
their hard green shells and we know the
Power Move for red turtles it's their
heat-seeking red shells but the Power
Move for a softshell turtle is
motionlessness yes Hank Kanter softshell
turtle covers himself with sand in a
river bank and then sits completely
still for 23 and a half hours a day
moving only when something crosses his
path that he can eat that actually
sounds a lot like my life only Cantor's
softshell turtle gets to live on the
beach and I have to live in Indianapolis
Power Move number seven belongs to try
go bat rack hiss robustus which is a
frog and when he's threatened he breaks
a bone in his own foot and then uses the
bone fragment from his compound fracture
as a claw to stab you pound move number
six is the cuttlefish so Hank cuttlefish
can turn into crazy colors they can
light up blue and green and orange and
yellow and they'll swim over to some
prey and they'll start lighting up as if
to say here's the party check it out I'm
a disco ball come and party with me this
is a crazy rave oh wait you just got
eaten power move number five baby potato
beetles Hank grown-up potato beetles
have hard shells which makes it harder
for predators to eat them but baby
potato beetles don't fortunately they
have poisonous poop it's so rare in life
that the word fortunately precedes the
words they have poisonous poop so what
the baby potato beetles do is they poop
and then they cover their whole bodies
in that poisonous poop to discourage
predators power move power move number
four Mavra elephant ophelia Hank we all
know that elephants have awesome power
moves like stomping and painting
pictures but I would argue that the moth
map relief ant Ophelia has an even
better Power Move which is feasting on
the tears of elephants yes Hank there's
a moth that gets most of its sustenance
from eating el
in tears and when the elephants aren't
crying enough on their own the moth will
go in and scratch it their eyes to make
them cry more power move number three
the Australian funnel-web spider
Hank everybody in America is so afraid
of black widow spiders but funnel-web
spiders in Australia are like for real
with their power moves for instance
they're very aggressive and their fangs
can shoot through human fingernails and
so scary someone had to call me about it
Power Move number two the duck-billed
platypus Hank not only are platypi one
of the very few mammals that lay eggs
they also have a sixth sense no joke
called electrolocation cloud if I can
use their fat little bills to sense
electromagnetic fields which means that
the moment one of their predators moves
a muscle literally contracts a muscle
the platypi knows which direction that
muscle is headed it's like a literal
superpower only it's contained inside of
a glorified beaver and Hank my number
one power move in the animal kingdom
goes to camponotus saunder see a
carpenter ant so hank when this ant is
in a fight and he notices that he's
going to lose instead of like fighting
to the death or whatever he gets as
close to his prey as possible and then
blows himself up these ants have these
poisonous glands that run the entire
length of their body and when they
realize they're about to lose a fight
they contract their abdominal muscles so
intensely that their entire body
explodes sending the poison flying
nerdfighters I can't wait to read your
favorite animal power moves in the
comments it's been fascinating to read
about all the diseases that you have
Hank I will see you and your last top 10
list on Friday don't forget to be
awesome